-So I have to congratulate you.
300th episode of "Family Guy"
is coming up.
-Yes. That is correct.
-That's incredible.
-Yeah.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Now that -- what is harder --
When you think back to yourself
as a child,
what is harder to conceive,
that you would do a cartoon that
would last 300 episodes
or that you would be nominated
for a Grammy
in the same category
as Bob Dylan,
'cause that happened for you?
-Yeah, you know, I wasn't even
sure I graduated high school.
So I'm like --
-Yeah.
-This is great. This is great.
-Are you still not sure
if you graduated high school?
-You know, we'll find --
I'll get back to you on that.
-Yeah. But this is -- So, your
album, you sing standards.
And you are --
You're nominated against
Bob Dylan,
which is really trippy.
-Yeah, yeah.
That's -- just
slightly intimidating.
-Yeah.
-And could be a problem.
Try not to get into a trash-talk
situation with him.
'Cause I feel you would not win.
-No, no, no.
-So you -- This is standards.
How do you select the standards
that you're going to sing
on each album?
-You know, I try to find stuff
that isn't too heavily overdone.
I kind of dig through
old Broadway cast albums,
through old songbooks.
I just try to find stuff
that is completely forgotten
so you can kind of
make it new again.
-And what are you singing for us
tonight?
-This is "Almost Like Being in
Love" from "Brigadoon."
-Okay, fantastic.
So that's -- you also --
I just assume,
and this is ignorance
on my part,
that people who can sing
are so great at singing
that they don't need
to work on it.
But you actually went and
trained with the same group
of people
that trained Frank Sinatra.
-They worked with Sinatra.
They worked with Streisand.
They've actually trained a lot
of singers over the years.
And they were both in their 90s
when I started working
with them.
-Are they --
Is it a family business?
-It was a husband and wife.
-Okay.
-That did this for decades.
And, you know, they both have
since passed away.
But they taught you
how to do it without help.
-And what -- so when you --
So you go in to practicing
with these two 90-year-olds.
Is there anything they told you
that you remembered?
Like, that was helpful?
-They claimed
they were still having sex.
I remember that.
-Really?
-Yeah. Yeah.
-And they said, "Look, if you
are ever trying to find
the emotional place for your
songs, just remember that
there are 90-year-olds
who are still going at it."
-Exactly, exactly. No excuse.
-Is it true you're supposed to
show your teeth?
Is that something --
-That is correct, yeah, yeah.
-Okay.
Now, I had not known that.
So explain what's behind that.
-Yeah, that's what
they always taught me.
When you sing, show your teeth.
As crazy as that sounds
because it brightens the sound.
And all these tricks are things
if you're singing live
or if there is no
post-production help,
You should be able
to sound good.
And that's kind of -- that's
kind of the way they work.
-Do you think they just, at 90,
had such an appreciation
for teeth?
[ Laughter ]
They were like,
"If I have any regret,
I would have shown them more.
I wouldn't got them out there
more before it was too late."
So, I also want to congratulate
you,
season two of "Orville"
next year.
So that's really exciting
to get picked up.
Congratulations on that,
as well.
-Thank you. Thank you.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Thanks.
-How -- so obviously, you are --
you have the "Orville."
You did "Cosmos" with
Neil deGrasse Tyson.
You are a lover of space.
-Yes.
-I want to ask
this hypothetical,
because it seems we're getting
closer and closer
to people taking
recreational trips to space.
Would you want to do that?
-I would not.
-You don't.
-At least, I wouldn't want to be
among the first group.
-Gotcha.
-I would want to make sure
everything still works.
Make sure everything is fine,
everything's in order
and then maybe I'll go up.
-Uh-huh.
-I'll be, like,
in the fifth or sixth.
-Gotcha. Yeah.
I guess that's true.
I feel like the most expensive
tickets to space
will be like five and six.
I think they'll have to discount
the first two trips.
-Yeah, you don't want to be
the guinea pig.
-Yeah. 'Cause I guess
the nice thing --
because you, with your show,
it's a very controlled space
because you are just doing it
on a sound stage.
-Yeah, yeah, it's much better.
-How has it been trying to
create a serialized show
that takes place in space?
Have you found it a different
challenge than "Family Guy"
in the writing?
-You know, it's nice
because there's shockingly
little comedy.
-Uh-huh.
Whereas "Family Guy" you could
argue is more packed with jokes
then anything on television.
-Yeah, yeah, yeah.
And it's kind of like I've been
doing comedy my whole career.
And I'm a big sci-fi fan.
And the thought of doing
something that is --
that's so far removed from that
was terrifying and thrilling
at the same time,
and, you know, I've loved it.
I've loved every second of it.
-That's great.
So I want to ask
about Neil deGrasse Tyson.
There is an asteroid
that is named after you.
He tweeted this.
I guess it's asteroid
70713 Seth MacFarlane
orbits the sun between
Mars and Jupiter.
No chance of hitting Earth.
-That is my given name,
is 70713.
-So how did that come about?
How do you get an asteroid
named after yourself?
-You know, I think it was
because of "Cosmos."
-Oh, okay. Gotcha.
-I think he kind of pulled
a couple of his strings --
-So that's basically --
if you want to get
an asteroid named after you,
cozy up to Neil deGrasse Tyson.
-Apparently so.
-Yeah.
-I knew he knew
a lot of that stuff.
I didn't think they called him
up and were like,
"Hey, man.
We're looking for a name."
But I guess...
-The politics of asteroids
is something that I'm --
I can't help you.
-And I've got to be honest.
I don't think
I'm ever going to learn.
I' just gonna -- I'm just gonna
let that take its course.
-It almost never comes up
at parties.
-So, it came up this week,
and I want to get your take
on this, as well,
because you're now living in
this world of sci-fi,
that in 2007, the Pentagon
basically put aside some --
I don't know if it's called
dark money or black money,
where they basically have been
checking out UFOs since 2007.
Like, this is money
in the budget.
Do you think that --
that UFOs maybe exist?
-From what I have read
and what -- in talking to Neil,
that what they were looking for
was not necessarily --
nobody gives a [bleep]
about aliens there.
-Yeah.
-They're looking for things that
might possibly be, you know,
bits of -- provide bits of
intelligence
from other countries, I guess.
I don't -- I think the UFO
enthusiasts sort of got ahold
of that and said,
"Oh, they're looking for UFOs."
-But I think it's --
I think it's highly likely there
is alien life.
I think it's highly unlikely
that we have been visited.
-Uh-huh.
-I think if we spent more time
listening for signals,
and less time, you know,
looking for evidence
that they had come here, I think
we're probably better served.
-Interesting. So you're saying
put the money into just like --
-Yeah.
-Like, surveillance.
-Listen to outer space.
Like, send out some, like --
you know, bugs.
-Or that, yeah.
-Look, I feel like they've got
to give us this money
and we can figure this out
because I would love to
get to the bottom of it.
Thank you so much for sticking
around and singing a song.
-My pleasure. Always.
-Always a pleasure to see you.
Seth MacFarlane, everybody.